[Music]
you've had so much success in the last
couple of years here in this country and
now you're getting to meet all these
cool celebrities and recently you met
the band one direction and you were very
excited about meeting one direction I
was because I know all of their songs
mm-hmm
I don't know what a beautiful do you
know that one yeah yeah no I don't know
any of their songs honestly yeah I
bought all of their albums ever had more
than one I have no idea no I did get to
meet them at Teen Choice Awards mm-hmm
and so I got to go into their dressing
room and some of them were like half
undressed and they looked at me and I
don't think they'd seen the hit movies
pitch-perfect or bridesmaids cuz they
were like here's this like desperate
loser coming in oh they would no they
weren't
yeah they were and then I said can I
have a photo and it's and they're like
yeah okay come on Ari let's just take a
photo with a and they get up like slowly
oh and then they like so I thought maybe
I'll just go out on stage and say good
joke about them uh-huh and I did so what
was your joke it was well isn't it funny
there's a band called One Direction cuz
that's also the name I give my [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Teen Choice Award so there
were thousands of 11 and 12 year old
girls oh dear they just went yeah yeah
yeah that was a complete silence I bet
yeah yeah I got censored you got on the
show yeah
also in my own show super fun night I'm
now getting censored a lot
oh really yeah I like what for example
jokes about dolphin rape you why do you
want why are you obsessed with doing
jokes about dolphin rape and first of
all our dolphins raping people what do
you like they jump out of the seat you'd
be like an Asian tourists all right
wanting to Pat a dolphin and you're like
and then the dolphin comes out and go
[Applause]
good acting by the way yeah really good
acting no well I'm with them first of
all I don't know how you wouldn't work
that joke even into the show what's the
second okay I'm sorry you're losing me
on this one I side but you're just
saying I'm sleep a fun night here the
other day where I had to wear a bathing
suit like I'm in a bathing suit store at
to come out right so I thought I know
I'll be funny
put some fake pubic hair on and so I
come out so the change rooms you get
some fake beard uh-huh okay I'm like old
man's beard okay put it this way it's
just about the right springiness I did
the same and it was hilarious like it
was and now the lawyers at ABC is saying
they can't show it right right
again I'm with them
I'm gonna go hit them on this one